le
regardez cette fusée qui décolle c'est
une fusée v2 en fait le premier missile
balistique de l'histoire des bombes
volantes mise au point par les
ingénieurs d'hitler pendant la dernière
guerre mondiale plus de 1300 d'entre
elles ce sont la bâtisse on londres et
plus encore sur le port d'anvers et même
quelques-unes sur paris
bonjour à tous nous sommes à eperlecques
à deux pas de saint-omer dans le
pas-de-calais nous irons également à
wizernes non loin d'ici et bien ce sont
sur ces deux sites des sites historiques
que l'on trouve aujourd'hui encore les
derniers vestiges les derniers
témoignages des armes secrètes du
troisième reich des témoignages faits de
pierres de ferraille et de béton tombent
des banques ça baume sur ses plaies
des tombes ça tombe un monde où tu
savais
bonjour hubert de magie bonjour vous
êtes le propriétaire de ce site
d'éperlecques et quand on arrive ici on
est extrêmement surpris par le
gigantisme du site est vrai qu'il s'agit
là d'un des blockhaus les plus
importants d'europe
oui si l'on le compas idée base sous
marine
je dirais non mais en volume et rien
extérieur effectivement c'est le plus
grand d'europe
alors se peut qu'on s'était très
rapidement construit finalement qu'il a
construit ce blockhaus à ce beau gosse
été construite en un temps record
puisqu'il a été construit en neuf mois
avec deux vagues de construction et les
allemands qui l'ont construit c'est
l'équipe de flou ce qui s'est occupé de
la construction de boucau d'éperlecques
comme la majorité des blockhaus qui
n'ont été construit sur le littoral
n'est en général c'est hitler qui a
décidé et voulu ce blockhaus un
blockhaus finalement extrêmement
polyvalent le logo éperlecques et une
usine qui regroupe une première usine de
réception de stockage 208 fusé après ces
fusées vont passer d'une deuxième chaîne
qui est une chaîne de préparation pas de
tir et après loin de pâtir commandé par
une tour de contrôle qui sera à
l'extérieur des locaux c'est à dire que
les fusées elle même ces fameux v2
n'était pas construit si il était
construit ailleurs en allemagne
les deux étaient construits adore d'une
ligne souterraine puis été acheminés
jusqu'à éperlecques via éventuellement
des silos de stockage et dc était prévu
de lancer 36 fusée par jour avec deux
potes tiers alors je voudrais qu'on
vient d'un petit peu sur la situation
géographique du site nous sommes en
pleine forêt la manche n'est pas très
loin
londres non plus londres qui est
l'objectif d'adolphe hitler et les
allemands pourraient pas trouver mieux
d'un triangle entre dunkerque boulogne
et saint-omer et calais sous les nous
sommes à l'intérieur des terres
à 25 km de la côte hors dé portée de
canon de marine seule attaque aérienne
p2 possible mais ce massif forestier
s'élève à 87 mètres d'altitude
donc les attaques resteront relativement
haute plus au moins vous êtes précis
alors ces attaques parlons-en
précisément les britanniques bien sûr on
a un oeil sur ce blockhaus d'éperlecques
et leurs supers forteresse leurs
bombardiers aussi sept ans 43 condé des
bombardements massifs
oui l'idée c'est de stopper les travaux
de telle manière égélement n'ai plus la
force et la puissance de redémarrer un
tel chantier avant la fin de la guerre
et il ya eu des bombardements et des
bombes tomboy donc tomboy qui sont des
grosses bandes 2,6 tonnes sont largués à
un peu plus de 5000 pieds et qui
arrivent au sol avec un poids d'une
vitesse un peu près tout le mc de deux
fois la vitesse du son
donc s'enfonce en profondeur au sol des
cocktails explosé devant le phénomène de
tremblement de terre et disloque un peu
tout et bien merci beaucoup et hubert de
mesnil au revoir et merci
après la destruction du low cost la
décision d'hitler et de son état-major
fut extrêmement rapide il est vrai qu'il
y avait urgence compte tenu de l'avancée
des forces alliées décision est donc
prise de transférer les activités de ce
site celui d'éperlecques sur un autre
site lui aussi destiné à lancer des
fusées v2 un site situé sur la commune
de wizernes non loin d'ici c'est à
quelques kilomètres je vous propose tout
de suite de vous y conduire
là
voilà nous sommes en route vers wizernes
juste quelques kilomètres alors il faut
bien comprendre que éperlecques et la
coupole que vous allez découvrir dans
quelques instants n'étaient pas les
seuls sites de lancement de cette europe
du nord occupée site de lancement bien
sûr de ses fusées v2 marie lebon vous en
dis tout de suite beaucoup plus les
bombardements d'éperlecques et wizernes
ont rendu nécessaire la mise en oeuvre
d'autres sites opérationnels de
lancement en sept années 1944 de
nouvelles rampes sont mises en action
dans le nord de l'europe
c'est aux pays-bas dans la région de mme
hidalgo puis de là et de reach que son
lancer la majorité de ces engins de mort
les côtes occupés se trouvant à
seulement 300 km de londres
la belgique est également concernée avec
les emplacements de gouvy et du plateau
de taille dans les ardennes mais au-delà
de ces sites lourd et statique toujours
sous la menace des bombardements la
décision est prise de mettre en place
des unités démontable mobile et légères
plusieurs dizaines sont déployés dans le
nord de la france en belgique et aux
pays bas par l'allemagne nazie pour
tenter d'affaiblir la grande bretagne
jusqu'à la fin du conflit
alors le voilà ce site de la coupole
cette coupole que vous voyez derrière
moi situé sur la commune de wizernes une
coupole où le gigantisme là encore est
de mise
magnifiquement mise en scène d'ailleurs
pour les très nombreux visiteurs
on
je rejoins julien duquenne vous êtes
directeur de ce site un site
extraordinaire on l'a vu déjà un site où
tout était conçu pour un lancement
j'allais dire industrielle de ces
fameuses bombes fusées v2 oui on est
vraiment sur une véritable ville
souterraine puisque en moins de 10 mois
ce site a été construit en moins de 10
mois il y à plus de 7 km de galerie 7 km
et le programme prévoyait d'en
construire 14
alors je voudrais qu'on dise un mot sur
ce fameux dôme extérieur qu'on y est
visible d'à peu près partout ici dans
cette région là encore c'est une
conception avec du béton du béton armé
tout à fait extraordinaire pour l'époque
oui c'est extraordinaire d'ailleurs
c'est la seule partie visible du
chantier du site
c'est un homme qui est construit à
partir de mars 1944
le chantier lui c'est octobre 1943 donc
c'est bien après et on décide d'avoir
une construction particulière s'agit de
propos de commandes hier de protéger les
salles de préparation tiers et donc à
partir de mars 44 ont créé un moule
directement sur la craie et on y coule
le béton
c'est la méthode de l'organisation de la
top ça et on coule le béton puis après
on gratte en dessous donc on construit
ça à partir de mars 44 et ce sont plus
de cinquante cinq mille tonnes de béton
qui vont être déversées dessus alors 55
mille tonnes c'est plus gros que le
porte avions charles de gaulle c'est
cinq fois et demie paul la tour eiffel
et c'est ceux d'hommes qui va résister
au bond qui vont être déversées sur le
site parce qu'effectivement ce dôme est
visible des alliés en particulier des
déceptions des avions d'observation
britannique est là comme à eperlecques
et bien sûr qu'il décide de détruire ce
site
pourquoi avait il intérêt à détruire
cette coupole à détruire ce dôme
il fallait la détruire parce qu'il
manquait plus que quelques semaines pour
rendre le site fonctionnel que
l'objectif finalement était d'envoyer
ses fusées v2 sur le centre ville de
laon
et de les envoyer un rythme cadencé de
50 fusées v2 par jour c'est à dire que
le programme prévoyait d'envoyer une
fusée toutes les demi heures sur le
centre ville de londres
merci beaucoup merci julien duquenne
alors justement ces fusées v2 on va en
savoir un peu plus ses lunes
j'allais dire des stars de ce site des
engins de mort des engins de destruction
mais également des anges en plein
d'avenir vous allez vous
à
bonjour laurent thierry bonjour vous
êtes historien ici même sur ce site
avec cette fusée v2 il s'agit d'une
fusée authentique qui est conservée
ici-même 14 mètres de long des milliers
de litres d'explosifs à la couze et
combien de morts pendant la guerre on
estime le nombre de pertes civiles a un
petit peu moins de seize mille
essentiellement en angleterre et aussi
sur le port d'anvers les deux
principales cibles dirigé par hitler
anvers et en import allié bien sûr oui
on dit également que cette fusée de par
sa construction à tuer encore plus de
monde chez les déportés qui l'ont
construite tout à fait le dès 1943 le
projet de secret il clair prévoit de
faire fabriquer ses fusées par les
déportés des camps de concentration
eux-mêmes et conflits à la ss ce projet
et les fusées v2 vont être
essentiellement produites dans le tunnel
du camp de concentration de doha en
allemagne là où
près de quarante mille déportés vont
être envoyés entre 1943 et 1945
et parmi ces quarante mille déportés qui
ont construit ce v2 beaucoup beaucoup de
français oui près de près de 9000
français 9000 déportés de france
essentiellement des résistants partie
dans les gros convois de compiègne entre
1943 et l'été 1944 alors cette fusée v2
c'est un bijou technologique d'une
certaine manière mais ce qu'on peut dire
quand même que c'est un échec militaire
militairement c'est un échec total
le les bombardements engendrés par par
cette arme ne rompt jamais l'ampleur des
bombardements classique de fait par les
alliés au dessus de l'allemagne à partir
de simples bombardier est pour toi ce
qu'on peut dire que c'est usé d'un bijou
technologique
c'est une les allemands ont réalisé un
exploit scientifique qui est à l'origine
de tous les lanceurs de l'après guerre
mis au point dans les différents pays
après la guerre alors il ya un homme qui
j'allais dire la cheville ouvrière de ce
projet qui aboutira au v 2 puis ensuite
à la fusée lunaire cette zone 5
c'est wernher von braun qui était-il
c'est tom werner von braun est un jeune
jeunes passionnés de fuser dans les
années dans les années 20 il a une
vingtaine d'années il est recruté très
très tôt et va diriger une équipe très
importante d'ingénieurs
sur un site
établie et spécifiquement à ce fait sur
la baltique un phénomène qui va être
chargé de mettre au point cette arme de
représailles lors ce qui est incroyable
c'est que ce wernher von braun
immédiatement la fin de la guerre a été
récupéré par les amériques
tout à fait
les américains ne pouvaient pas se
passer de ces cerveaux entre guillemets
pour pour eux continué dans le cadre de
la guerre froide surtout vis-à-vis de
l'urss à à exploiter ces projets et
continuer à mettre en oeuvre ses projets
qui aboutiront à la conquête de l'espace
et
marcher sur la lune merci laurentien
le v2 vous l'avez compris un échec
militaire donc un vecteur de mort et de
beaucoup de souffrance et pourtant une
technologie qui après avoir envoyé les
hommes sur la lune permettra peut-être
demain d'envoyer des êtres humains sur
la planète mars
jean claude leroy et sénateur du pas de
calais il est très impliqué dans les
histoires dans l'histoire de ces
territoires
c'est un terrible paradoxe d'avoir le
meilleur et le pire de la science et de
l'homme aussi d'une certaine façon et
c'est la raison pour laquelle la coupole
se veut d'abord être un outil
profondément pédagogique autour de
autour du thème à la fois de la
résistance mais de ce que peut être
aussi la perversion génère de la science
et la région ou département manifesté le
souhait d'ailleurs que chaque jeune
puisse au cours de ce qu'il a été visité
au moins une fois la coupole parce que
c'est une leçon une leçon une terrible
leçon mais le son sur ce qui a été jeudi
refont l'histoire la coupole c'est le
lieu où s'est joué le sort de la seconde
guerre mondiale je crois que tout le
monde n'avait pas conscience à dire mais
c'est ado aussi naturellement de prouver
que effectivement et et de démontrer que
le sort de la seconde guerre mondiale
s'est joué à la coupole
voilà c'était jean claude le roy le
sénateur du pas de calais de quoi
nourrir votre réflexion certainement sur
les paradoxes de l'histoire c'est la fin
de cette émission à très bientôt pour
une nouvelle édition d'un lieu une
histoire